إذا كانت إسرائيل حقك ومرة أخرى ، فإن ال
ؤال هو كيف نجعل إسرائيل تق
م تنازلات ، فلديك نزاع إقليمي ، كي
وصلنا إلى هنا ، ل
د تعرضت إسرائيل للهجوم عدة مرات عبر ال
اريخ ، وكذلك في الحروب الدفاعية ومن خل
ل تلك الحروب ال
فاعية.  قادرون على احتلال الأراضي منذ
أن فعلوا ذلك ، لقد تمكنوا من
الازدهار كدولة أصبحت
قوة عسكرية عسكريا ، هم قوتنا
الاقتصادية من الناحية التكنولوجية الحكيمة
وهم يقومون بعمل جيد للغاية
لديك الفلسطينيين لديك خمسة
ملايين فلسطيني  الأشخاص
المحاصرون تحت القاعدة التي لديك الآن
لديك السلطة الفلسطينية
زعيمها الذي أعتقد أنه
رجل يريد السلام هو في العام السادس عشر
من ولاية مدتها أربع سنوات ، لذا فهي ليست
ديمقراطية مزدهرة في  في هذا
الصدد ، لديك دولة بوليسية
لديك وضع لا يملك فيه الناس
الحق في الازدهار عندما عقدنا
مؤتمرنا في البحرين ، كان لدينا جميع
رجال الأعمال من جميع أنحاء العالم
جاءوا للزيارة ، لقد كان شيئًا رائعًا
إلا أنهم لم يأتوا لأن
قيادتهم كانت تدور في الأساس
لتوزيع منشورات تقول إن لدينا
رصاصة لأي شخص يريد القدوم إلى
البحرين ولكن اسمحوا لي أن أنهي هذه النقطة
النقطة الحقيقية التي جاءت  انطلاقا من ذلك ،
كان ذلك المؤتمر هو أن
الناس كانوا يقولون إننا نهتم
بالشعب الفلسطيني كان يموت من أجل الاستثمار
لخلق فرص عمل هناك ، لكن لم يقل أحد
أن إسرائيل كانت هي المشكلة ، وقالوا
إن المشاكل ذات شقين
لا أحد يريد أن ينفق رأس المال
في  مكان يوجد فيه
خوف من الإرهاب لا يريدون
نقل شعبهم إليه ولا يريدون
القيام باستثمارات حيث لا يوجد
استقرار للحكومة مما يعني
أنك بحاجة إلى اتفاقية سلام
، والشيء الثاني هو أنك بحاجة  أن يكون لديك
هيكل حوكمة جيد
سوف يتدخل ويقوم باستثمارات رأسمالية
إذا لم يكن لديك حقوق ملكية إذا
لم يكن لديك سيادة القانون ولذا عليك
أن تسأل  لقد كانت الذات الإسرائيلية
كبش فداء مناسبًا جدًا
للسلطة الفلسطينية ، وبالمناسبة كانت
السمة الموحدة للعالم
العربي والشرق الأوسط على مدار السبعين عامًا الماضية
للابتعاد عن الكثير من أوجه القصور
داخليًا في الكثير من هذه البلدان
ولكن  بالنسبة للفلسطينيين ، إذا كانوا يريدون
لشعبهم أن يعيشوا حياة أفضل ، فلدينا الآن
إطار عمل للقيام بذلك إذا لم
يعتقدوا أنهم يستطيعون الالتزام بهذه
المعايير ، فلا أعتقد أنه يمكننا حمل
إسرائيل على المخاطرة بالاعتراف
بهم على أنهم  دولة تسمح لهم
بالسيطرة على أنفسهم لأن الشيء الوحيد
الأكثر خطورة مما لدينا
الآن
هو دولة فاشلة وقد رأينا ما
حدث في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط عندما
يكون لديك دول فاشلة
والمخاطران اللذان يسببان  أمريكا من خلال
الإرهاب من خلال التطرف وإلى
جيرانك